uh i am not gay do like the gals uh i  went on a date with a girl once i went  pretty well went back to her place i  take out a condom she goes whoa whoa  whoa where'd you get that thing  i was like well they were free at the  bar  she was like oh that's gross  i was like well that's where i got you  and you know these are all just jokes i  don't mean to offend the gals i try to  be a good feminist i do which is tough  nowadays because some women are  feminists and some women aren't so as a  guy how do i know how to act like some  girls you open the door for and they're  like wow a gentleman thank you very much  other girls you opened the door for them  they're like what you think i can't open  my own door i'm like whoa hey i'm just  trying to sleep with you  cheers louise how do we get here